SPEAKER: So first of all, I
want to welcome all of you.
If you have hummed
even a handful of songs
over the last couple
of decades, there's
a 99% chance that one of those
songs were sung by Sunidhi.
She began singing
when she was four.
And there was nothing ruki
ruki about her, Sunidhi,
once she started singing
as a four-year-old,
but then also later
in 1999 for "Mast."
She has been nominated
for a total of 81 awards,
including 14 Filmfare
and 14 IIFA awards.
And I wish, Sunidhi,
you brought the picture
of your mantle piece
because we sure
would like to see how
it looks like to have
22 of those awards on there.
Sunidhi, it's my
absolute pleasure
to have you here at Google.
Thank you so much
for making the time
despite having to sing tonight.
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN: Thank you for
the wonderful introduction.
Thanks so much.
SPEAKER: So we were lucky enough
to be on the route of your tour
that you're doing in North
America with Shri Balaji
Entertainment.
You were singing in
San Jose yesterday.
Tell us a little bit more
about your upcoming events
and how this tour has
been turning out for you.
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN: This
tour has been fantastic.
I mean, we've performed
in LA, San Jose.
I've lost track already.
Orlando, Houston,
and one more city.
Where?
OK.
So basically, we've
had fantastic shows.
And the kind of response I've
received from the audience,
the love, the affection,
is incredible,
has been incredible.
And the last time I came
here in San Jose to perform,
it was one of the most
memorable times for me.
And when I performed last
night, it was even more magical.
So thank you so much for making
this so special each time.
That's all I can say.
SPEAKER: OK, thank you
so much for coming.
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN: And
my forthcoming shows
are going to be in Dallas,
Seattle, and Vancouver.
And then we're done
with this tour.
I'm going back
home after a month.
SPEAKER: It sounds like
you can't wait for that.
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN: It's not that.
It takes so much from me.
My shows take a
lot of hard work.
And all the effort that has
gone in there, me and my band,
is humongous.
So we get tired.
It's as simple as that.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
You started singing at a
very early age of four.
But then also in terms of your
career, you started that at 13.
Right?
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN: 11.
SPEAKER: 11, even younger.
What does go on in the
mind of 11-year-old?
Does she know she's
building a career?
Is she following
someone's advice?
Or is she just following
her passion at that time?
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN: Nothing goes
on in one's mind actually.
It's just I was like
a tape recorder.
Dad used to ask me to sing.
I would sing and then head home.
That's all I knew.
My job was to sing.
So I would never take the
credit for being who I am.
My dad struggled on my behalf.
He gave his life, his career,
his everything because of me.
And he gave up everything.
And I am what I am
because of his sacrifice.
So yeah, but then by the
time I got a little famous
and had a lot of
songs to my credit,
then my struggle started.
Then I had to
maintain what I had.
I had to keep going
strong and stronger.
Each time I sang a song, it used
to be like a new song to me.
I used to treat it
like my first ever.
And that's how it happens.
That's how you should
treat your work.
And another thing is
that, thankfully, I
am in love with my job.
It's not a job for me.
It was a hobby when it started.
And it turned into a profession.
When it did, I don't
even come to know.
So I'm glad that I'm
doing what I love.
SPEAKER: We can
tell from your work.
It doesn't look like-- it
looks effortless despite there
being so much effort.
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN:
Thank you so much.
SPEAKER: So you have sung in
many different genres of songs.
Right?
You have sung a very
folk-based "Bumbro."
You have also sung a very
racy "Sheila Ki Jawani."
How do you bring that much
breadth into your singing?
And do you prepare
at all for that?
Like we have heard
that Amir Khan,
for example, when he
prepares for his movies,
he tries to live that
character for many, many months
beforehand.
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN: Yes, a
little in my head, but in five
minutes because
there is no time.
Maybe for a movie,
to act in a movie,
you still have time to prepare.
But for people like us,
we go to the studio,
learn the song in about 10, 15
minutes, and we are on the mic.
So it's a very fast process.
But we are used to it.
SPEAKER: Great.
And out of all these different
genres that you have sung,
what is your favorite?
If you had to make
a song on your life,
what genre would that be?
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN: I'm
yet to find that out.
I don't know honestly.
I have thought about
composing actually.
Maybe yeah.
Thank you so much for the idea.
I would like to write my
own music maybe someday
if you would like to hear it.
SPEAKER: I would
love to hear that.
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN: But
sometimes, you're a singer.
They just want to
listen to your singing.
They don't want to hear your
songs that you've written.
So it's good.
I would love to
explore that area.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: I would
love to hear it.
And we found out a
little bit about your-- I
have one last question
actually about your success
outside of India.
So obviously, you have reached
the pinnacles of success
in Bollywood.
You've just done many, many
songs in many, many movies
and outside of movies.
So after that, you have had a
stint also outside of India.
You sang a song along Enrique
Iglesias in 2010, "Heartbeat."
Tell us a little bit
about that and if you
have any future plans of
doing more outside of India
engagements.
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN: I am
open to collaborations.
With this song, with
Enrique, it just came to me.
And I got excited.
Thankfully, there
was enough scope
in the song to blend some
Indian element into that song.
So we did it.
And it sounded good.
Otherwise, it always
sounds a little off
when you try to push something
which is probably not meant
for that kind of music.
But it just worked.
The folk and the pop song,
it just blended together.
I mean, this is for all my
fans and who like my work.
I recently acted
in a short film.
And it was a great experience.
So go check it
out when it's out.
That's all.
It's called "Playing Priya."
It's a short film.
It's only going to be released
on the digital platform.
So you can check it online.
And please feel free to comment.
If you like it, great.
If you don't like it,
please, all the more comment.
I would like to know.
SPEAKER: And as you can imagine,
we are very active on YouTube.
So we will comment.
SUNIDHI CHAUHAN: Yes, great.
Thank you.
Thank you again.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]